he used me to please his own desires
because clearly his wife wasn't
satisfying him these da guys make
me brothers and sisters just imagine for
a second that you give £10 in donation
and that £0 is used to buy food or
bricks or whatever to help the people in
Gaza but then just imagine this amazing
de that you want to do but we turn it
into a moneymaking machine how the W is
exactly that they take your money and
the money that we are going to put in in
this W this building and every single
time the money generated from that W
that building is going to go to our
Palestinian brothers and sisters for the
next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years and
this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subh bless and preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends the da predators are at it again
my co- Predator Aki aan has been uh
Court should we say I mean there's
evidences apparently we're going to read
them so here is a message from a sister
who has been obsessing of Aki a
obsessing over Aki a for God knows how
many how long and once she realized she
cannot get away and break his marriage
after she did s and magic and has been
making D his marriage to this black b t
c h she's been saying this by the way
can you imagine his wife and there were
Sisters by the way when she posted this
uh thing which came later he she has
been we're going to go through all this
messages Etc and look how how dangerous
it is for us Brothers in the da scene
when we're dealing with the enemies of
Islam from the Zionist to the Christians
to the Jew these are hostile ones not
all of them are the same yeah to the
Liberals to the enemies of Islam from
the far right and not only that now we
have our hijabi sisters who have accused
all of us da Brothers as Predators who
are just uh praying on the vulnerable
yes but they would never ever talk about
this how I experien myself personally
these kind of things nude pics invite
being invited to places Etc not being
married trying to lure Us in so they can
expose us now we've got our dear hijabi
Muslim sisters who are trying to catch
us out by using something that out is
our greatness weakness which is
themselves females yes but we're going
to categorize them we're not going to
fall into the nonsense they do look at
these text messages look where can I
meet you and marry you my love I make
Dua for you every time to be mine
obsessive sisters look can you read my
messages it's urgent my love when will I
be your wife this yeah and it's going to
get worse by the way we're going to come
to the accusation the accusation yeah
when will I be your wife me and you will
be the right we will be the right I pray
every day that you distance yourself
from your wife yeah and I pray
it's working because you are making
story about this answer my messages up
until now you don't message me where can
I meet you and marry you yeah look look
look guys look why have I been blocked
from the live can you open my messages
open my messages look obsessive and once
they don't get their own way oh yeah
women are not narcissist at all it's
just men manipulation never women and
manipulation oxymoron M gaslighting uh
uhuh it's all the men it's all us we men
are just narcissistic manipulative
gaslighting evil dirt bags Salam alaykum
I have been hesitant to message you this
I want to marry you because I know you
will be that missing love in your I will
be that missing love in your life you
even said you no longer love your wife
which is a lie in the podcast and I was
so happy because I felt I feel my duas
every day is working I cannot stand you
are married to a black person and guess
what guess who was defending her when
she came out this accusation that akan
committed zenner with her five times
black sisters she's talking about his
black wife yeah are you going to defend
her now yes I cannot stand it you are
married to a black person and I pray
every day every day you divorce divorce
her or she dies and I pray for your love
for your love for her decreases she does
not deserve you and I feel deep down
your daughter is not your child you
should get a DNA test I will do
everything I can to be your wife I want
to be a spirit spiritual I I went to a
spiritual man last year and he did
Islamic things to make me get you and I
just know just now want you because the
thing he done is taking longer than
expected look he done on AK and his wife
to divorce them what does Allah say in
the Quran and they use S for what to
cause separation from man and his wife
wom going to do s but the sisters will
not talk about it our sisters will not
talk about it Sol sisters they won't
talk about it sister Oma she won't talk
about it either no no no no no no yep
because men are guilty until proven
innocent and they are innocent until
proven guilty he told me to go back to
make it stronger can we meet please I
love you so much give me a chance now
when that didn't work what do these
sisters resort to we have experience
let's see what they are going to resort
to here we go the chance to see you my
babes up close I will have I will have
your water and everything you need laid
out for you I can't wait to talk to you
and can't wait to see you inshallah that
of a wife of yours yours has cheated on
you and that baby is definitely not to
yours people in the comments in the
video of that girl showing her hand
combing her combing her hair people say
the color is too white how many signs
are you going to ignore look at this
look how that's what Allah in the Quran
the plot of a woman is it's great when
they go into the plot it's great the
plot of Shan is weak but the pl of a
woman is you know the story of saying
every single woman but when they went to
PL oh my gosh yeah take a step back take
five step back um the GU ain't yours I
make what every day that you your wife
drops dead it makes my skin Cru knowing
my future babies has been with a black e
now once none of the works what did they
resort to now what when this whole
situation with Zade came out and Zade
made his apology and apologize for the
mistakes I made and repented om say
she's saying that she can you imagine
she sadly accuses us all that guys to be
the same and she hasn't apologized for
that forget that now she's saying that
she's got enough to apologize for and
then she talks about narcissism and she
talks about manipulation so you don't
believe you have to apologize for
labeling all our da guys the same and
making it seem that Zed proposed you
when he didn't that he wanted mut
marriage when he didn't yes I'm not
saying it's on purpose manipulation but
that is manipulation yes okay and anyone
I don't care if big Alum of this D comes
and tells me that you did not manipulate
that is manipulation not on purpose but
that is misconstruing yes or he wanted
temporary marriage all that kind of
stuff and you have not apologized to
what happened she came out this sister
and says like his friend Zade Aki aan
has been talking to me and has met me
many times and had sex with me on five
occasions the voice note was sent to me
acting as if it was me that was wrong
like he's a pi man Aki a pinned the
blame and acted as if I was bothering
him after using me for sex look at this
Aki a was interacting with me with no
intentions of marrying me he used me so
I can't help but laugh but something
said to me when I met him in person he
used me to please his own desires
because clearly his wife wasn't
satisfying him these da guys make me so
angry do you see the trend these da Guys
these da Bros this da men and sisters
like are still lying against all of us
and liking start saying these da guys
this and that you have started this
trend you have started this trend yes is
anyone going is anybody going to come
out to this no they're not this is this
is and now they are lying against us now
they are lying against us and a a that
he committed Z this is the this is a
slander that requires 100 80 lashes 80
Lashes in public in Islam slander
slandering a married man because you are
obsessive over him and this is where it
boils down to guys most of the times the
sisters want to marry da guys yeah yes
and th guys do not bat an i because we
know what kind of woman they are we're
not going to marry that kind of woman
you think I'm going to come marry you
think we're going to marry such woman
who are flipping tapped in the head to
bring them into our house alhamdulillah
the woman that we have married
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah I look at the new next
generation of woman that these and I'm
not saying all of them some brothers are
going to marry may Allah protect may
Allah have mercy may Allah have mercy on
the next generation of woman you're
going to marry
because that's all I'm going to say I'm
going to end on this do you see this
trend now of these da now it's come to
the level would any of those sisters who
made videos about Zade came out when
before the truth came out about Zade
what he actually said would any of them
come and jump on this our Sol sisters
are you going to come out and speak
about this are you going to come out and
speak about this is it going to happen
no it's not these is the greatest of
Slanders to accuse a married man of
committing zner there will be 100 lashes
sorry 80 lashes this is the hypocrisy
we're talking about this is why it is so
great brother sisters when it comes to
your tongue the prophet said the one who
guards between what's between his lips
and what's between his legs I will
promise him give him the Good Tidings of
Jenna Surah was revealed about the honor
of a woman slander how dare you guys
these sisters accusing all of us da guys
and point us into the same category why
because you do not like the way we give
dawa why because we tell you A woman has
to be submissive and obedient because
men are polygamous by Nature because if
a man calls his wife to bed and she says
no she'll be cursed by the Angels you do
not like Islam it's not the da guys you
have a problem with Islam like that
Mariam uh French toast feminist who
calls Hadi misogynistic your problem is
with Islam not with the da Bros or the
da guys you do not like the fact that we
tell you this is what Allah subhana in
his messenger said you hated you call it
religious blackmailing religious abuse
you don't like Islam your problem is
with Islam not with the da voice we come
and tell you what Islam said we when
when we quot we the maintainers and
protectors and we have to work we don't
complain we don't cry you do not like it
and we will never stop it we're not
going to come here and sugar quot it for
you and yeah no no no you have to be
obedient to your husbands alhamdulillah
yes and that's the reason why there's so
many a Hadith mentioning this okay and
you like it or not rip your hair out
like I said go to Turkey and get hair
transplant that's all I'm going to say
inah may Allah preserve and protect
brother AK am's marriage our dear
sisters honor his wife yes and these
evil women who are lying perpetrating
these evilness alhamdulillah and you
will never see these sister coming out
speaking about it that's all I want to
say inah may Allah protect and preserve
brother amen inah and there's a lot of f
like this may Allah protect us from such
woman alhamdulillah allow us to be
married to women who are besides us
alhamdulillah and may Allah bless and
preserve you guys asalam alaykum sor